de l'engagement des conditions
climatiques difficiles et du suspense ce
dimanche au 10 décembre les
clayes-sous-bois qui évolue en bleus se
sont offert le derby vinoy contre
montigny le bretonneux son adversaire
direct dans la course au maintien
indécis jusqu'à la 90e minute 7
rencontres de première division de
district s'est débloquée en faveur des
clés siens score final 1 0
dans les dix dernières minutes ça allait
vraiment d'un camp à l'autre on récupère
un ballon assez haut donc
une passe un peu l'arctique halles qui
fait qu' on est deux sur le même ballon
et un contrôle d'un décalage son côté
une troisième passe devant le but mais
le budget c'était juste le plat du pied
s'est réduite de son côté montigny le
bretonneux concède sa sixième défaite de
la saison la deuxième de l'année dans
les arrêts de jeu nous on a les
occasions pour tuer le match et puis
l'arbitré nonce deux minutes on va
pour ce pouvoir au moins faire un match
nul parce que c'est ça même avec un
match nul on aura été déçus puis repart
avec zéro point grosse déception
au classement cette deuxième victoire
permet au promu que les siens de passer
devant son adversaire du jour dilutif
c'est le maintien
clairement c'est monter en excellence on
arrive sur la pointe des pieds parce que
ça fait longtemps que le club avait
quitté cette division a assez de se
maintenir mais bon ça va être difficile
mais gare à ne pas céder au tournant
après la trêve hivernale les
clayes-sous-bois reprendront le
championnat le 21 janvier 2018 contre
epône de son côté montigny le bretonneux
jouera un match en retard contre ou ce
dimanche 17 décembre à l'extérieur avant
de penser aux vacances